Have you recovered
after that explosive ending
to Money Heist Part 5,
Volume 1?
Us neither,
if we're being honest.
And we totally understand
if you've got lots
of questions,
probably starting with why?
And then moving swiftly onto
when is Money Heist Part 5,
Volume 2 coming out please?
I can't wait any longer.
We'll forgive you
for missing the bit
where
this information appears
in big red letters
right at the end.
You were probably
breathing heavily
into a paper bag
and that's okay.
Money Heist Part 5,
Volume 2 arrives on Netflix
on the 3 December.
Five final episodes
that will bring this story
to its conclusion.
Is Lisbon an undercover cop?
This is a big question.
We know from Part 1
of Money Heist
what a skilled negotiator
Raquel Murillo is.
She even outwits Tamayo
and saves the robbers
in Part 5,
while the Professor's
out of action.
We also know she's a woman
of principle and loyalty.
Yes, the Professor's clever,
handsome, and charismatic,
offering Raquel
a romantic dream
of wealth and freedom,
but would she really
throw her entire career away
just for one man?
Or is Raquel's
indoctrination
into the gang,
her adoption
of the codename Lisbon,
and her acceptance
into the Professor's
trusted inner circle
all part of a wider plan?
If she is
still working undercover
for the Spanish authorities,
Raquel has hit the jackpot.
The Professor has let her
in on all his plans
and she'll have
enough evidence
to take him down.
But the truth is
we just don't know.
If Lisbon is a police mole,
then we can add
Oscar-winning actress
to her sizable
list of skills
as her emotional attachment,
not just to the Professor,
but the entire gang,
is plain to see.
My presence
changes everything.
Extraction
is the priority now.
Does the Professor
truly love Lisbon?
On the other side
of the equation
we have the Professor,
a master of foresight
and planning
and tactical genius
and inspiring orator.
But a man who quite clearly
has a strong emotional bond
with those
he now considers his family.
Look at how much
they all mean to him.
You can see it
in his face...
hear it in his voice...
I'm sorry, Raquel.
I'm so sorry, Rio.
I'm sorry, Palermo.
Okay, we get it.
Thanks, Professor.
At this stage,
the fact he loves Lisbon
is not really up for debate
as evidenced by his reaction
when he thought she'd died
at the end of series 3.
But whether or not
the romantic relationship
has taken root in
a game of cat and mouse,
the one they started
during the royal mint heist
in series 1,
is a question the answer
to which we won't know
with 100% certainty
until Part 5, Volume 2
arrives on the 3 December.
Will Alicia join the gang?
Alicia Sierra,
disgraced police inspector,
torturer, lone wolf, mother,
but will she ever be
part of the gang?
It's difficult to see
any other route for Sierra
at this point.
Publicly shamed
and betrayed by Tamayo
and her former
police colleagues,
she's essentially on the run
with her new born child,
Victoria.
A logical move would be
to join forces
with the Professor.
He's the one
with the dirt on Tamayo
that could clear her name,
plus her attempts
to comfort the Professor
after the events
at the bank,
would suggest
her icy hatred for him
is thawing somewhat.
But Alicia Sierra is nothing
if not unpredictable.
She's also smart,
resourceful,
and already has displayed
a willingness
to do whatever it takes
to get the job done.
Checkmate, son of a bitch.
Is Arturo Roman still alive?
It doesn't look great
for Arturo, does it?
Gunned down by Stockholm
after a bungled attempt
at playing the hero,
the last time
we saw Arturo Roman
he was being wheeled
into an ambulance
with a bullet
still lodged in his chest.
As Palermo
succinctly puts it,
his chances aren't great.
He was dead a minute ago
and he'll be dead again
when you stop blowing air
into his lungs.
Still, this is Arturo Roman
we're talking about.
An abusive scumbag
with a special talent
for showing up
at the most
inconvenient moments.
We wouldn't be surprised
if he had some part to play.
Even if it's just
as the trauma-induced
hallucinations
of a guilt-ridden Monica.
What happened to Tatiana?
The character of Tatiana
has been the subject
of much speculation.
There are some who think she
and Alicia Sierra
are one in the same person.
A fan theory dismissed
by actress Najwa Nimri,
but it's certainly possible
Tatiana could have
a significant role to play
before the end.
The widow of Berlin
and therefore
the ex brother-in-law
of the Professor,
Tatiana is important
in that she almost certainly
has knowledge
of the bank heist plan,
seeing as it was Berlin's
brain child to begin with.
How this will play out
is anyone's guess.
But eagle-eye viewers
will have noticed
the look she shared
with Rafael
as they sealed the way
with stolen Viking gold.
If you really want
something in life,
you have to steal it
from whomever has it.
What will the Professor's
next move be?
This is the big question.
Tragedy has truck
and the gang is desolated,
but for all the heart break,
the robbers are in
a far better position
than when we joined them
at the beginning of Part 5.
The Professor
is back in the game
and holds important leverage
over Coronel Tamayo.
Sagasta, Gandía,
and their team
of special operatives,
are defeated.
Alicia Sierra knows
the extraction plan
for the gold, but crucially,
the Spanish authorities
do not.
And last we saw,
the melting operation
was back on.
Either way,
the Professor's priority
will surely be
to extract the gang
with no more casualties.
Well, if that's with
or without the gold,
only time will tell.
What's the meaning
of "Bella Ciao"?
and why do the robbers
always sing it?
The unofficial anthem
of Money Heist and the tune
we've unashamedly belted out
in the shower
pretty much every day
since Money Heist debuted
in 2017,
"Bella Ciao" a traditional
Italian folk song
that translates
as, "goodbye, beautiful".
Allegedly
first sung by women
working in the fields
of Northern Italy
in order to pass time,
"Bella Ciao" took on
political significance
after being adopted
as an antifascist anthem.
The song became synonymous
with the Italian
Partisan Resistance
who fought against the Nazis
and the Italian fascists
during WWII.
Since then, "Bella Ciao"
has been sung worldwide
as a hymn of freedom,
an anthem
representing rebellion
and liberation.
So, it makes total sense
why Money Heist's
beloved family
of bank robbers
would adopt "Bella Ciao"
as their own.
Here's a group of outcasts
ostracised by society,
fighting for their freedom
against
the perceived tyranny
of the oppressive
Spanish state.
Take it away, gang.
Let us know in the comments
how you think Money Heist
will play out.
Give us a like
if you enjoyed the video
and subscribe
and click the bells,
so you never miss anything
on your favourite shows
and movies.